Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P, here is a caller asking about how
can it be good to eat vegetables if babies
don't like them?
It's weird.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
In the context of evolution, yeah, how is
it possible that we eat vegetables and fruits?
Given children's reactions to them.
You know, it's like pulling teeth to get a
child to try a piece of chocolate.
Like throughout history, I. Did we eat properly?
Oh, I think I know because we have no other
options available.
And compared to anything else, you know, if
you're starving, it's like hunger is the best
place.
Okay, answer my own question.
Thanks a lot, David, for for not doing anything
useful to help and leaving me to my.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy.
So, anyway, how do vegetables make sense in
terms of human evolution and babies don't
like them?
Listen, my daughter likes every vegetable
and every fruit.
I mean, sure.
Mango.
How can anybody not like a mango, but raspberry,
blackberry, pear, everything.
I don't really know what the caller's talking
about.
How could it be?
I guess the idea would be if if babies and
little kids instinctively reject fruits and
vegetables, it would suggest that evolutionarily,
blah, blah, blah.
Well, but babies also don't forage for food
on their own, so it doesn't really matter.
It's a matter of whether the parents are giving
the babies fruits and vegetables.
And it makes a lot of evolutionary sense because
they provide essential nutrients and vitamins
and minerals and antioxidants.
So, you know, sugar that gives us energy satisfy
sweet cravings in fruit.
And it seems to me that eating fruits and
vegetables is perfectly in line with evolution,
although it sounds like the caller doesn't
actually need my help figuring it out.
I don't know if you have anything you want
to ask or say.
You can call 219 to David P on the bonus show
today.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We will talk about a U.S. fighter
jet response to an unresponsive aircraft near
Washington, DC.
The aircraft ultimately crashed near in Virginia.
What happened there?
We will discuss.
Saudi Arabia cutting oil production specifically
to increase prices, this time acting unilaterally.
Some in the US aren't happy.
What does it all mean?
We will discuss it.
And lastly, what's happening with Disney is
just so, so funny.
Disney continues to welcome LGBT individuals
and families as the battle with Ron DeSantis
continues to rage.
Folks, I don't think this is a battle Ron
DeSantis has even a chance in hell of winning.
All of those stories and more when we are
joined by producer Pat on today's bonus show.
Please sign up at join Pacman dot com.
You go a long way to supporting the work we
do and it feels good to sign up and say I'm
a David Packman show member It's a great thing.
Just got an interesting email actually about
two women bonding on a flight about their
David Packman show memberships.
Very interesting story sign up at join Packman
dot com.
We'll see you on the bonus show we are here
all week.